[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
the murder of nba star lorenzen wright i
just made bad decisions because i was
scared 12 years later will his ex-wife
make parole plus rico and felony charges
for rapper young thug why his lyrics are
being used as evidence and whitney my
sister all of a sudden put herself
in between johnny and i what witnesses
you could expect to see when the johnny
depp amber heard case reconvenes but
first was the tara grinstead
investigation botched it happened and
it's my fault we head to georgia where
ryan duke stands trial in the beauty
queen's murder law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer as the
murder trial of ryan duke stretches into
a fourth day testimony zeros in on a key
piece of evidence in the early days of
the tara grinstead investigation
grinstead a small town teacher and
former beauty queen went missing from
her georgia home in 2005. in 2017 ryan
duke and beau dukes were arrested and
charged in her murder the pair are not
related prosecutors say ryan duke
confessed to killing grinstead after he
broke into her home later both dukes
helped burn her body near a pecan
orchard
duke's attorneys later said he was under
the influence of drugs during the
confession in 2019 beau dukes was tried
and found guilty in connection to
grinstead's death for years the only
clue investigators had was a latex glove
found on grinstead's property in the
early days of the investigation ryan
duke's dna was later found on the glove
during opening statements the defense
told jurors three dna profiles were
found on the glove but expert testimony
rebutted that claim
why
did you choose to swab the inside and
the outside of the glove
so in 2005 as i stated a little bit
earlier
this was the first case that i did
that involved touch dna that did not
involve a fluid as far as i knew
so the thought process was to maximize
the amount of dna because i didn't even
know that i would get anything
i figured i probably wouldn't because we
usually needed a lot of dna
so i swabbed both sides
in order to maximize the sample to see
if i could get any profile the testing
that we do now can detect a much smaller
amount of dna than back in 2005.
okay
so
when you swab this glove
um did were you the actual person that
did the testing to see if you were able
to identify
any dna yes ma'am and can you tell us
when you swab the glove item one um did
it reveal any dna yes it did and can you
tell us was that of one person or more
than one person it was more than one it
was a two
after that retired georgia bureau of
investigation agent gary rothwell took
the stand he told jurors the names of
both ryan duke and bo dukes were on
investigators radar but were mistakenly
dismissed early on
are you familiar with whether or not any
of your agents
um
summaries or reports that they did in
this case included the names ryan duke
and bobox yes
to your knowledge
was a follow-up ever done by gbi agents
as to the document that was cont that
was from another agency that had their
names no
to your knowledge was a follow-up ever
done in relation to their names being in
one of your agents summaries
no
why
that is a question that has
bothered me for years
and i have talked to other agents and
reviewed the documents and and come to a
recollection of what happened but it's
not an excuse for what happened
the information was
was received as if it was
had been addressed by local law
enforcement is unfounded
that was a presumption that we should
have never
ever made
but it happened and it's my fault
joining us today is forensic death
investigator joseph scott morgan and
co-host terry austin joseph it seems
like everyone is focused on the dna of
this glove but what are you most
intrigued about in terms of forensics in
the ryan dukes trial
well i think going forward uh the
exclusion of a third person remember the
defense had said early on that there
were three uh gonna be three identifiers
here and we only come up with two and
and then i think probably from a
forensic standpoint we'll hear more
about that in the upcoming days brian
and that is
the rendering down
of tara grinstead's remains and the
level of callousness and dehumanization
that took place with her body remember
this wasn't just a one-and-done kind of
thing according to bo dukes during his
testimony and what he had admitted to
and confessed to eventually was the fact
that they had stayed out there for a
protracted period of time
up to two days tending the fire making
sure that there was nothing left of her
and they almost accomplished that task
yeah it goes
goes towards a lot of the motive and the
thought process going on with those
defendants terry so is it two or three
dna profiles and does that affect the
credibility of the attorneys in front of
the jury
well you know it does sound like there
are three profiles and if that's the
case the prosecution really should have
mentioned that anytime you have a
weakness in your case
and that would be perceived as a
you need to raise that issue and you
need to do the best you can
to explain why there were three profiles
other than the victim and the person
that you are pursuing as the defendant
and if you can't explain it or if you
avoid it all together the jury is going
to think you're trying to hide something
and they're going to think the
credibility of your client is really at
question so you need to talk about it
right at the beginning all right we'll
see how they'll handle that as the case
continues and probably into summations
as well switching gears now to federal
court where 28 year old nathan carman's
charged with murdering his mother at sea
to receive a hefty inheritance carman
was arraigned in federal court on
multiple fraud charges and one count of
first-degree murder six years after he
was rescued off the coast of new england
federal prosecutors say he rigged his
boat to take on water and killed his
mother linda carman in the process her
body was never found prosecutors claim
linda carman's death comes as part of a
years-long inheritance scheme starting
with the death of millionaire john
checklist authorities allege carmen
killed shakalis his grandfather back in
2013 for half a million dollar payout
carmen has not been charged in that
death this week he pled not guilty to
fraud and first degree murder charges in
the death of his mother
still ahead on law and crime daily
rappers young thug and gunna are
arrested on rico charges in jordan but
first x's johnny depp and amber heard
face off in a multi-million dollar
definition lawsuit who you can expect to
see on the stand when courtney convenes
[Music]
welcome back to jurors in the johnny
depp versus amber her defamation lawsuit
can expect a string of new witnesses to
shake up the case next week including
actress ellen barkin and johnny depp
himself
this week lawn crime network confirmed
that both witnesses will be called after
herb finishes testify jurors can also
expect to hear from herd sister whitney
henriquez all this comes as part of the
multi-million dollar defamation suit
stemming from herd's 2018 washington
post op-ed about domestic abuse depp
sued for 50 million dollars for
defamation and heard countersued for a
hundred million dollars doubling down on
abuse claims
while testimony has not yet focused on
ellen barkin heard sister whitney has
been mentioned throughout the trial
notably when heard testified about death
swinging at her sister that's when heard
says she retaliated physically for the
first time
whitney my sister
um
all of a sudden put herself
in between johnny and i
uh she just threw herself
like in the line of fire or whatever she
just
all of a sudden there was trying to get
johnny to stop
her back was to the staircase
and
johnny swings at her
and i just
see my little sister with her back on
face
her back to the staircase
and johnny swings at her and i don't
even
wait and i
swung at him
and all of my relationship to date with
johnny
i hadn't landed a blow
and i
for the first time
hit him
just days before heard's testimony depp
security guard told jurors a different
story saying depp never swung in whitney
i stepped
in between misheard and mr depp
telling
mr depp that we were that we were
leaving and that it wasn't up to him
anymore
um
at that point
out of the corner of my eye i saw a
fist
and an arm come
across my right shoulder and uh
i heard and saw a
closed
contact
mr depp and the left side of his face
and whose fist was that
that was misheard's fifth amber herd's
fist
well in fact you saw mr depp uh push or
shove whitney hurd correct
absolutely not and it was only after mr
depp pushed whitney that amber stepped
forward and punched him in the face
isn't that right not correct
so terry whitney is likely to
corroborate her sister's version of
events and i know in criminal law we
would call her an interested witness and
the judge would explain how to evaluate
her credibility is there something like
that in defamation trials
well you know in the civil context like
a defamation case here you have to
follow the rules of civil procedure and
an interested party there is someone who
really would have a financial interest
in the outcome but there's no doubt that
even though whitney doesn't have a
financial interest here unless her
sister sort of shares the gain if she
gains anything she is someone who the
jury could consider having bias because
of the relationship with the defendant
here with amber heard so the judge
basically could give a jury charge on
any person who might have buys based on
their relationship but we'll see what
happens at the end of the day but she
definitely is going to be in amber
heard's camp and testifying on her
behalf absolutely now joseph no one died
in this case so you may be just a little
overqualified for this trial but if her
and all her people say one thing and dep
in all of their his people say another
how are we supposed to tell the truth at
the end of the day
it's very difficult and when you know i
think one of the things that kind of
rings with me yesterday we we were on
air and we were discussing the image of
amber heard with the blackened eye
and the busted lip and you know one of
the things brian about domestic violence
cases and uh
to a degree also child abuse cases uh
is it's very difficult to set a timeline
with injuries if unless you get to them
very very quickly and have somebody that
is proficient and skilled in that area
to evaluate i would have loved i'd love
to see a trauma specialist maybe even a
pathologist get on get on the stand and
describe those injuries that are being
purported in that image that she's
saying originated with a headbutt yeah
it'd be interesting to see i know even
some people have suggested maybe a botox
expert to talk about the light bruising
under the eyes but we'll save that for
the lawyers coming up on law and crime
daily 12 years after the murder of nba
star lorenzo wright his ex-wife cheryl
wright is up for parole plus young
thug's lyrics are used as evidence as
the rapper faces recoil charges in
georgia
[Music]
welcome back rapper young thug is
charged with a slew of gang-related
crimes in atlanta this as the musician's
lyrics are used as evidence in the
investigation
rapper young thug whose real name is
jeffrey lamar williams and gunna whose
real name is sergio kitchens were among
the 27 people arrested on gang-related
charges according to an 88-page
indictment they conspired together to
illegally obtain money through
racketeering prosecutors say young thug
is the leader and founder of the gang
the court documents used lyrics from
young thugs popular songs and social
media posts referencing ties to gang
activities including quote i prepared to
take them down and quote i never killed
anybody but i got something to do with
that body young thug's attorneys say
this claims or these claims are baseless
saying the young thug stoner life record
label imprint is not a gang he also
faces seven additional but separate
felony charges including possession of
marijuana with intent to distribute and
possession of a firearm in court this
week both young thug and gunna were
denied bond
so terry you heard some of the lyrics i
know you're a big fan of young thug you
could probably wrap some of it for us as
well but things like i told him to shoot
a hundred rounds and i shot it at his
mama uh now he no longer mentions me or
just some of the lyrics being used to
prosecute him is this allowed in court
actually brian it is allowed rap lyrics
have been allowed in the past one of the
most famous cases is the late rapper
draco the ruler the prosecution there
introduced lyrics now eventually he was
acquitted but it was allowed and in this
case the lyrics appear in the indictment
and the prosecutors are you know
alleging that those lyrics constituted
an overt act and furtherance of the
conspiracy but they're gonna have to
prove that and i think what young thunk
is gonna argue is he has a valid first
amendment argument that words shouldn't
be used against you that you have a
right to express it as an art form and
so we'll see what happens but i think
that's a great argument a first
amendment right argument yeah you're
saying it's art and not reality
definitely strong argument now joseph
one of the crimes young thug is accused
of setting up is actually a hit on a
rival gang member and rapper who was in
jail at the time what went into an
investigation like this to bring about
these charges
well any time you enter into
uh you know this is a rico violation so
you have a group of people that are
coming into a criminal conspiracy into
the realm of criminal conspiracy a
confederation if you will
and you know brian over the years when i
examine these cases in the media and
when i've worked cases in the past
there's always a weakest link there's
somebody that has something to gain by
rolling over on somebody in the crowd
and so if you're in prison and you're in
custody and someone uh you know pulls
you aside and says take someone's life
well that might be the key to get out
for you you know and you're free from
the prison life at that point in time so
there's always a weak link in the chain
all right we'll see what that chain
leads us in this case as it continues
thank you both when we come back will
sherra wright be granted parole the
ex-wife of lorenzian wright pleads her
case and explains what led up to the nba
star's murder
[Music]
welcome back more than a decade after
the murder of nba star lorenzen wright
the board recommended his ex-wife be
denied parole in the murder
lorenzo wright was reported missing in
july 2010 his body was later found in
the tennessee woods near his mother's
home seven years after his death
investigators recovered the murder
weapon in a mississippi lake after that
billy ray turner was arrested and
charged with wright's murder prosecutors
say wright's ex-wife cheryl wright
recruited turner to shoot and kill her
ex-husband they say she was after the
basketball player's life insurance
policy earlier this year turner was
convicted for wright's murder in 2019
sarah wright was sentenced to 30 years
in prison for facilitating the murder at
a parole hearing on wednesday sarah
wright explained what led up to her
ex-husband's murder and how she feels 12
years later
leading up to the murder
we got
my son was approached at his school and
he was threatened lorenzen jr was
approached at his school and he was his
life was threatened
and they wanted his dad's whereabouts
because they because lorenzo went into
hiding while all this was going on it
was a target placed on me and my kid's
head he's like nah what you need to take
it into is that insurance policy that
you got on him because you can um pay
him that way because i'm not gonna die
i'm not gonna be caught up in this and i
was like well you know what this is what
we're gonna do everybody's gonna get out
away from my kids and off my porch and
everybody and he's gonna handle his own
business and his own debt and that and i
started hauling off and saying things
like
yeah so if it's gonna if you think it's
gonna be me and my kids no it's gonna be
him take him to take him
to them i told them to take him
to lorenzo but i do want to say that i'm
sorry for what happened to him i'm sorry
because he's not here i'm sorry that my
kids don't have a daddy and his mom
doesn't have a son and they don't have a
niece's
and i mean they don't have their uncle
and their
their nephew and all the people that i
consider to be my family i didn't want
to see anybody hurt the way they're hurt
right now and i didn't want to ever ever
in my life be without him because he was
the love of my life
i just made bad decisions because i was
scared
joseph that's an interesting explanation
and a very emotional uh plea there but
did shara wright's words move you enough
to think that she should have been
granted parole or did the board make the
right choice
i think they made the right choice uh
you know too little too late in the very
first segment
there was not even a hint of contrition
in there whatsoever
and it's terrifying it's terrifying that
she's begging right now to get out of
prison
after the way
they hunted this man down out there in
this wooded area near his mama's house
and shot him down shut him down like a
wild animal and it was absolutely
horrendous the fact that that they would
even entertain
she would even entertain that she should
be walking free among us is is
terrifying to me yeah now terry that
leads us to this question then based on
the trial the conviction everything we
know about this case and what shara
wright has said just there
when do you think she would be paroled
or do you think she should ever be
paroled
frankly brian i agree with joseph i
don't think she should ever be paroled
certainly not now maybe after 30 years
but that was a brutal murder this is
someone who trusted her he's the father
of her children he was literally running
for his life as joseph mentioned it was
cold-blooded it was calculated it was
for financial gain and if we have her
back out in the public first of all
there's absolutely no real punishment if
she gets out anytime soon and if she's
out in the public who knows what else
she might do for financial gain so no
parole now and no parole later
i will give any updates as the this case
continues with more parole issues thank
you joseph thank you terry and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
so
[Music]
you